hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
animal cell culture media so
cells need media to grow
obviously the nutrients which are
important for cellular growth
should be present in this media right so
in this video we would look at the exact
media components
and how they promote cellular growth
you might be familiar with these kind of
pink bottles
or reddish bottles where there is media
right and you put it on
cells and you expect the cells would
grow and divide but have you ever
wondered what is exactly inside those
bottles or what is exactly inside those
fluids
this video would give you an overview of
that
so let us review the requirements of a
cell to grow optimally
in a culture condition so the cells
need controlled temperature which is 37
degree centigrade
provided by the cell culture incubator
because that is the temperature
cell needs inside our body to grow as
well
other than that it needs a substratum
for attachment
especially especially if the cells are
epithelial cells they need a substratum
for attachment
which is inside our body which is the
basement membrane
now appropriate growth medium which
would have the growth factor is required
and lastly the incubator is required
which would
maintain the ph and osmolarity of the
media
so different cells have different growth
requirements
because all the cells are not dividing
every time and each cell has different
kind of metabolism going on
so their growth requirements are also
different for example a
kidney cell a neuron or a hepatocyte
they have a very different growth
requirements
but at least at a simplistic level
all of them need something in common and
let's review that part
so a minimal media would have the
following components
it would have some kind of antibiotic
cocktails
which would ensure that there would be
no growth of other microorganisms
glucose as a carbon source amino acids
as nitrogen source
vitamins for optimal growth and
nutrients
serum which would contain hormone and
growth factors
buffers which would maintain the ph of
this
solution attachment factors which would
help the cell to get attached to the
substratum
and lastly some kind of inorganic salts
which would work like micronutrients for
the cells
so all these factors are important
in the cell culture media for the
cellular growth
now the proportion of these components
might vary depending upon the
cells that we want to culture but these
are the basics one
also the cell culture media has
particular indicators such as phenol red
which indicates from a range of ph 6.5
to ph
8.5 this phenol rate tells us that the
condition of
media is good or bad for example at ph
6.5
the media would be yellowish in color
and that would tell us instantly that
the
media requires a change as soon as
possible
or there could be contamination in the
media that is why
this looks like this kind of pale yellow
now
if it looks like this orangish color
then
within a day it should be changed if it
is extremely reddish then the ph should
be around 7.4 and it's perfect
it's it's not requiring any change
immediately
now if it is pinkish that means the co2
concentration
is somehow altered and co2 supply need
to be checked
so all of these different ph range
indicates
several important aspect of the cellular
health or the
condition of the media so that is why
putting a
indicator in the media is crucial
now cell culture media can be divided
into two types natural media or
artificially or synthetic media now
natural media
has growth factors other important
components of
cellular growth but these media are
actually
undefined that means highly variable
it can support the cellular growth but
for
experimental point of view or for a
laboratory research point of view
these are not really useful so
artificially synthesized media would
have all the components
which are balanced and batch to batch
there would be very less variation
this would ensure the reproducibility of
the experiment as well
so the all the components that we have
mentioned earlier would be present
in a particular proportion no matter
which batch we would use the proportion
would remain the same that's why
using artificial media for culturing
cell in lab is really important
now let me tell you a very important
component of the media and that is why
people are saying
serum containing media or serum free
media
serum generally is derived from
fetus of bovines and now this fetal
bovine serum would be really important
for animal
cell culture because they have
all the necessary growth factors and
hormones which would
augment the cellular growth let me tell
you in details what serum contains
so generally with a cell culture media
10
fps is added but what's the role of
fps let me tell you frank that all the
cells
need growth factor for division without
the growth factor
cells really cannot grow or divide so
serum contains
mitogens mitogens are substance which
would promote mitosis
or which would promote growth so
generally these mitogens work in a
complicated signaling pathway
and they give rise to specific cyclin
and cdk
complexes such as cyclin d now this
cyclin d
helps the cell cycle progression from g1
to s phase
as a result what happens the cell
divides
and grows inside the media now if
mitogens are absent cyclin d would be
not produced in adequate amounts
that would not allow the cell to divide
properly
and that is how the cells cannot grow
inside the media condition so it's
absolutely essential
that we provide some kind of source of
these growth factors or mitogen
it's not necessarily have to be serum
because serum is also variable in terms
of
composition because it is extracted from
an animal right
so now our days there is a huge usage of
serum free media
serum free media would also have all
these necessary factors but in a
synthetic synthetic fashion like all
these serum
free media are synthetic media that
means growth factors are there
but they are artificially added in a
particular proportion
even better right yes it is better
but the price of these media are
quite high so the commonly used
media is commonly used serum replacement
is
known as knockout serum replacement so
which would not have the components of
the serum
but it would have all the necessary
factors in adequate fashion
other than that there could be special
additives like special cell types
requires
may be concentrated lipids
because many cell types such as stem
cells requires lipid concentrates to
grow
non-essential amino acids could be also
required by
several cell types but it really depends
upon cell to cell
many of the researchers use fungi zone
or pen strip for
prevention of growth of fungus inside
the cell culture
so let us talk a little bit about the
contamination part because cell culture
media is so much
enriched that other microorganisms such
as bacteria fungus or
even micro microplasma can grow inside
the cell culture media
that is why it is important to put
proper
antibiotic cocktail or antifungal
cocktail such that
these growth would not happen because we
want our cell to grow
not these contaminations so let us look
at the contaminations
in bit more details so this is how a
bacterial contamination look like under
the microscope you can see
these small dot-like structures which
are floating all around the media
are actually bacteria there are
mycoplasma
shown in the figure microplasma
contamination is detrimental for the
cell culture and they are highly
contagious
then fungal contamination you can always
see the fungal hyphae
developed in your cell culture dish so
all of these condition if you see
then these cells cannot be grown any
further and they have to be discarded
in a proper biohazard bag
and this is how you need to culture your
cells
so i hope this kind of summarizes all
the important topics
regarding cell culture media if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
thank you